[Música]
estamos recogiendo la red de pesca
en la red, ¿verdad?
para
llevar el pez rápidamente a tierra para
los clientes compran comida para llevar para el almuerzo
Es en poco tiempo con un modelo de pesca.
que no es sostenible desaparecerá
no sólo los cardúmenes sino varias especies
Va a desaparecer pronto, ¿no?
Encuentra más
[Música]
Escucha, hay que tener confianza porque el
El pescado que no es fresco no mola, ¿no?
[Música]
para los que terminan
de pescadores que tienen algo de historia
con la fiesta de manualidades por algunas razones
No querían continuar con su profesión.
de los padres de los miembros de la familia y luego el proyecto
también tiene la intención de rescatar
esta tradición en estas familias trae
esta gente vuelve a la fiesta
hecho a mano
[Música]